hello everybody and welcome back to
drunk minecraft with me me me Bob and
Wade port me we're wait Bob where'd you
go away you went down where'd the
dollars that you were talking about
screw you guys I'm out of here
what are the doors you were talking
about I go to the center and there are
some levers and then you drop straight
down into the water and now I'm in a
sewer Marcy okay I got it
where are you down Wade by Wade mark why
are you battling with that bag chips I
could hear that why am I on fire again
people on Saturn community one she burst
into flames I had nothing to do with me
finding you Wade you're such a dick
I think Wade has a flint and steel he's
not near me if I had to guess he's not
I'm pretty sure you're near you I'm
going I'm going some direction but I
don't know where hey I found the exit oh
wait water here we go okay
all right anyway guys everyone watching
who if anyone's still watching no that's
watching this this is awful terrible
just oh [ __ ] shut down all the trash
compactors on the detention level all
the trash compactors oh oh I'm getting
crushed son of a [ __ ] oh happy if that
was your mother's voice
I would I would have a [ __ ] oh please
nope I got ported and I got to keep all
the stuff a phantom yes oh well we find
that rube again I'm not gonna tell you
and we're all gonna die cuz it's really
funny why the hell am I on fire
Wade you're such an ass bag oh there you
are Bob
there's no wait I swear I don't know
what's going on he's right behind you
idiot oh maybe this way it's been me all
the darkness okay stick okay never mind
then wait just an [ __ ] Tommy can you
make wait-- naked here's a dick he has
it what he is a dick you're a dick
job zombie I don't think we can kill
each other either so I'm not really
gonna go anywhere I can't sprint you've
increased my salons where are we going
oh these are sewers you're right oh oh
how could you like push me away why is
that happening cuz I'm good this
dead-end oh no it isn't oh yes it is
that's not two dead end uh-huh it's a
dead end
it's not this end is dead it's very dead
[Music]
Oh balls it is a dead end
you're an [ __ ] I should never have
given you that flinch still funny part
is I'm not even using the Flint in this
deal my sword has fire aspect why cuz I
picked the right chest okay whatever I
don't care wait would you hurry the [ __ ]
up Ryan it's not letting me sprint
forget are the vines if you just do
spray it hold it it'll let you sprint
when there aren't vines I have been let
how am i moving faster than you I don't
know God cuz but Wade's way ahead of ya
I was until I fell in the water though
this is a dead end oh you just want to
get the chest dick already did still a
dead end
oh this is annoying he's [ __ ] vines
man behind the trash compactor I don't
know why don't you tell us where we need
to go I don't know it was you know
around one of these corners uh let's
specifically ransom the way back out
well don't go that way
that's not the right way I was where I
went down every single path obviously
not because I found a room where I died
a bunch you didn't die at all stop being
such a melodramatic Queen your drama
King drama queen a melodramatic queen
king you know Bob I weighed I will I
will destroy your family they're all
dead no I am don't follow me I'm dumb I
wasn't trying to you were on accident
ice trying to look up and see what you
were doing mmm Oh adventure is hard it's
just more like maze hero zombies lost oh
boy Oh team ah whatever don't matter
quality entertainment yeah well there's
been a we've been really boring you're
boring I mean into the last episode
nothing blew up I think we should go
back to zombies server and do that thing
where we fight mobs what mom does those
those arenas those were fun we could
abandon this adventure map pirate ships
is an option oh yeah you guys oh yeah
we're gonna do that cuz [ __ ] this temple
it's not that kind of thing
we should decide before we start
recording Oh
we're gonna hey I'm running away
hahaha I bye zombie give me tea if we're
gonna abandon this you're gonna button
steal and give me I can't place it
and give me some wool gonna be placed
TNT everywhere oh yes fancy and tea
Rob and I are gonna fight for the day
we're gonna go out with a bang it's not
gonna end well for me I'm gonna hide on
the ceiling more many much more almost
got that oh boy oh no no I'm okay well
I'm actually gonna die please don't kill
each other before the explosions oh boy
[Laughter]
10 pitch give god mode on mark no I do
not
you're just get back get back here hey
beggar you son of a [ __ ] I will destroy
you
stupid diamond armor how didn't you kill
Bob oh no you don't oh no you don't get
it out here you guys suck if I could
kill myself I would with you why won't
you die why would you stop me heal me
Dobby heal me thank you and cheap smite
Lord minion smite Wade smite smite me
it's Mike let me right in the face Mike
him yeah
I was crushed to death by the ruble okay
all right log out so we can let job'
transfer over are we going to his server
another sir going to he's gonna switch
it up to the pirate ship it's ready
already
yeah log back on I'll just work you okay
I'm still in the game zombie because I'm
not a [ __ ] Bob holy crap now I've got
new items yeah welcome to the club dick
welcome to club my items oh no they're
gone they're gone
they're going away I'm hitting all the
switches cannonball there's a pirate
ship well what do you what do you expect
it to be shut up wait wait I will
destroy you okay teams me and zombie
versus Bob and Wade that sounds like a
terrible idea that doesn't sound fair at
all I'm John Dory fair and this is
intense
no it's on a ship that's the point of a
map load fire how do you load there's a
button down here said load load all
right here I'll show you guys an example
how to load this thing I'll show it from
our side I'll do I'll do both sides load
some TNT this is a primer right here how
are you Oh God we're going down
alright do-over
oh I'm back at the temple oh hell what
the heck they got back at our big
exploding creeper just crapped TNT at me
is that good in the first place Bobby I
need to be warped where are we dude Oh
bring it I had to I had to reset the map
because I totally destroyed that one
ship yeah alright alright so let's do
this over again this is well I'll bring
you guys always yeah alright here we go
okay I'm gonna plan a plan on our ship
yeah you can't plant on wood dumb-dumb
shut up mark you don't know me I'm
taking all the TNT where'd my sapling go
it was my SAP don't give this yet Bob no
one no one gives you okay so this how it
works okay look you drop some TNT or
that red wool is okay this button loads
it the more you put in the farther it
will go so you can do something you can
do less you can do more you can make it
uneven if you want to make the shot like
veer off to the left or right and then
when you have enough TNT in there this
is the cannon ball ignite the propellant
wait a few seconds ignite the cannon
ball hahaha oh my god this is awesome
wait Baba mustn't you or Oh God
it's like the best thing I've ever seen
in my life
load node that's who's on my ship I am
I'm on zombies people it's just the
greatest thing ever go go why do you
know fire oh damn it
oh [ __ ] - early I think I just blew up
the ship I won't fire wait you're an
idiot
Oh God what I did Kenan no function oh
my god this is not a good thing for us
to do as drunk people no no not at all
this this is never gonna work
it's just gonna be like we need to reset
the ship's Oh mark only have one cannon
less
let's call this a practice round and I
got all these cannons blown Oh God oh I
see you got a wait a few look a little
bit longer to drop the Cannonball it's
exploding before it even gets launched
out of the ship that's why it was
exploding oh [ __ ] way to go there I I
sunk the ship
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] hmm can I get warped over there
again zombie maybe on the other ship
load up some fresh ships oh yeah get
that I don't know about fired a cannon I
don't understand how that last one blew
up in my face
I thought I did it and then killed
myself okay here we go buh buh boop
super juice in we're shot no I never say
that in front of me ever again
Boop super juice ever say those words
those words are banned why I don't know
can I get ported or no I'm standing in
the beginning of that last thing we did
boom yeah I am I win I won right that's
me winning
yeah I win i won i won
oh hey it's a giant [ __ ] I blew in
the boat go team there's not a single oh
yeah this is all man not none no cannons
on this ship is functional mmm because
of that sound right there we got this I
like how there's a map and I got this
right
I got this wave watch watch a pro handle
this okay I know you kind of suck at
life and all that but watch this
ready Oh dick
Oh direct head Oh where's the sword we
need to board their ship I don't think
it works that way
ah everything I do and uh Bob you know
what you should do
Bob Oh Bob you should play World of
Warcraft with me I I don't have that
game you know I mean I don't have a an
account oh because I recently reinstated
my account oh wait I got Diablo 3 back I
talked to I called them up on the phone
and got in the situation and they were
understanding and they got me the Annual
Pass back so I got Diablo 3 again oh my
characters are back nice yes um
beautiful you get to renew war war craft
room yeah I had to renew my subscription
to world of warcraft but it's not that
bad better than paying 60 bucks for the
game yeah I agree
well then we should play Diablo 3 yes
that should but well I'm gonna hold off
it's good nice bit I'm gonna hold off on
be able for you until it patch 1.04
comes out because that's one [ __ ] - it's
good and it's better for co-op then
they're doing a lot of stuff to improve
it in the next patch like like all of it
is it wow wow what that disco disco
so-so
zombie what well what is this force wave
yeah this is the other one that I I got
oh oh I know what this is the killer
wait a minute I don't think I want to be
down here wait get here no I have no
permissions is that good oh why is there
TT behind that glass window don't ask
why T and T was just taken where are you
oh I see what's going on I have no
health and Bob and I are naked
I don't even see you how are you it's
right here no I don't see him no one's
here but you but mark whatever but you
Wade no that's that's not the case Wow
some do freak out okay falling through
the world Bob stop being a dick now you
guys are dicks you killed us why are we
dicks cuz he killed me before times when
you shot a pirate ship cannon at me that
was awesome
direct hit with a cannonball right in
your face that was awesome come on not
awesome no okay
mommy can we get ported thank you
alright so this game work okay this is
how this is supposed to work you guys
get there's a chest here it's got some
bows and a couple arrows zombies will
flow in from that face on the opposite
end which I think they're on their way
over here and then you guys need to fend
them off before they get all the way
over here
pressing these buttons here on the wool
will launch a TNT depending on the color
so like I think if you press the red one
it will launch a TNT that goes pretty
far okay see that nice Wow nice shot
where's Wade just uh you killed me
not even on my screen zombie I can't
wait and I see each other I'm falling
sure okay okay all right I see some
strange stuff the only thing the only
thing you'll be careful about is firing
off the tee and he can it's too fast cuz
it will just destroy the whole thing
okay I call the error no arrows I had
one error I have no arrows are we
supposed to have arrows well yeah but
the bows have infinite on the money but
I have no arrows so I can't fire
anything fire there we go
if I jump down there can I get back up
is that a thing yeah yeah jump down
there's a there's a ladder alright I'm
taking all this experience [ __ ] bags
seriously why can't I see Bob now Bob I
can't see now we have unlimited arrows
but yeah the bow is enchanted with
incident I believe yeah
if you get one arrow it'll never die out
okay send the next here we go I'll fight
them off yeah you do that
number me if I shoot you because I can't
study you not my fault
stop wasting all the TNT how do we get
it to go it's not going I'm pretty sure
the force wave maybe okay I click that
nope oh yes there it is there dessert so
quick turn PvP Austin oh I think those
my kill there we go there we go ah there
we go alright I won't get anything I'm
getting down there you're welcome I
don't see you Bob but I'm down here with
you I don't see you I'm down are you I
don't know what to do you close to me
yeah
wait hit the force wave again okay Bob I
see arrows do you see this oh yeah oh
yes we're here said oh we got Bob it's
away deep dick why would you do that
look out
yeah asked exploded ding I didn't see it
till it landed there are villagers down
here what's there villagers down here I
don't see villagers
yeah the they're being used to make the
zombies charge all the way towards the
place where you stand
okay wait hit the fourth wave I'm down
here next to you and there's zombies
coming toward us
oh no I don't like the fact that Bob's
up there by himself with the cannons
ah okay not beating let's get down to
brass tacks here is serious business
why are you guys so quiet why Bob I'm
gonna say that was on purpose
boy there's a lot of stuff back there
get me holy hell okay so we broke it
that's cool I said all of a minute
wow that was fun while it lasted oh my
well Bob we can't trust you with
anything apparently nope well just stay
in chat and then go play like Starcraft
I just talked to you guys so I'm
shooting arrows but I can't see them I
know there's so weird we can't see each
other I hear I hear footsteps
what happens if Yuri log I don't want to
all right I'm gonna go back to the other
server because
blow up the rest of my town good luck
jet left to blow up I don't wanna blow
up good hey Bob you [ __ ] Oh Bob why
aren't you talking
why does suede have diamond what is this
well I have this from Lilith ah what hey
what hey there are signs here way to get
out of the way Salvage on what you can
but people still live here lit locked
houses indicate that the house oh [ __ ] I
advise to knock I could was reading that
did it blow up yeah you blow the signs
way to go
hey who's messing with my TNT Bob I
would I will destroy you I didn't do
anything
oh you're such a dick are you guys so
much better
that's I'm walking off we need you we
need you no no please no please why were
you carrying a minecart with a furnace I
found it Oh almost got you wait oh God
any objective that we might have had has
just been lost rebuild just rebuild no
pvping rule [ __ ] the rules but zombie
what other adventure maps do you have in
store
I have that amnesia map but I don't have
the amnesia texturepack all right well
that's okay I mean it just kind of adds
an extra layer mm-hmm
it's up to you there's like just
hundreds of adventure maps and I could
just I know there grab any of them well
grab one that you think is interesting
not the amnesia one but something you
think is interesting and we'll go back
to it all right right now we're just
gonna blow [ __ ] up hey Mark what texture
pack are using right now so VAX so facts
facts wait they lost money oh yeah wait
I will take all that you love
I can't even port back to my town now I
have no money so much I hate still ah oh
[ __ ] balls they hang on
and we're off [ __ ] out and we're back
I wasn't [ __ ] you guys made me twin how
about and that screwed up the recording
hey you so much oh you so much Oh
[ __ ] hell
I have scrapped [ __ ] you're the worst
Oh oh my god that is so bad that is my
back now again Oh God we were never gone
I don't know anything again
I cut recording because I thought that I
was an idiot oh you are it idiot yeah I
still don't know about it I had it we're
okay now we're okay hey Stevens you're a
spam in a bit
Stevens J needs to be banned does he
really think that jizz [ __ ] is that
offensive
how dare you say that how dare how dare
Jay Jay cool used to be banned as well
yep okay Jay Jay Jay Jay cool there we
go
yay huzzah
why Bend why not then these people are
idiots okay now we're back that crisis
was averted and we're all good now we're
all good
that's uh up to interpretation what are
we doing I forget I am loading up the
next map okay cool
all right we're getting there I can't
even get back to my town so I'm just
jumping around the spawn point doing
absolutely nothing that's kind of we've
done this whole video Shia we've done
stuff we watched Bob screw up like three
maps yeah I break a lot of maps yeah not
that one with the mobs the waves of mobs
is actually getting fun and then you
just had to blow everything up well I
couldn't load that back up while I get
this next one ready if you guys want
sure sure okay can I hop over to the
other server yeah okay mmm I'm back in
Ashe do you wait why why as I didn't see
it you saw me I was right you aimed for
me
I aim to the chicken you murdered me
even me that's the best part
you did and you're not gonna get away
with it I will destroy I was Laura no it
was not you were such an [ __ ] I'd
swear I did not see you you aimed
exactly for me how could you not oh oh
no I'll go away it was not possible for
me to spawn and you randomly turning in
360 degrees pick that direction and then
kill me I see you know now I'm aimed at
you yeah don't hey which server are you
guys on the adventure server the other
one when we were on yeah we're not
permitted to build now we can see each
other okay this is good yeah that's much
better
I see you guys don't kill each other
I'm hungry
I'm not permitted to build yeah zombies
coming he's busy bow chicka wow well I
don't think that busy
alright now you should be able to play
the map okay but not permitted to build
so I can't get the arrows really still
yes don't yeah that's a lot of tnt down
there no wonder it all blew up oops
I don't know how Bob did that I mean I
spammed the cannons for a while and it
didn't do anything yeah this is Bob is a
an extraordinary at destroying
everything we love I was kind of trying
to do it to be clear I think I'm lagging
because I'm really the same piece of
zombie flesh for about a minute and my
health is gone what is going on I have a
arrow no no they nice don't kill each
other
uh miss me I can't do anything
well yes ah bees busy loading up another
map so we'll get here in just a second
everybody watching probably bored to
tears at the moment yeah I did
Oh what the [ __ ] did I just do I I
jumped I I see you actually I don't
I [ __ ] up there oh you are there we go
okay ha all the bows are mine I now have
all the bows who needs a bow hey you
need a bow here um where am I don't care
we're starting Luke there we go I'm done
for where are you
what how falling through trees here have
a have an arrow have a bow and have one
arrow here arrow behind you why you Ohio
arrow there thank you where's the chest
at it's gone I picked up all those
permissions shoot yeah I think the
permissions are messed up but I think I
see what mappers and votes it's working
shoot the zombie but I can't shoot an
arrow if I don't have any permissions
either are you really there shooting
yeah yeah yeah you can't shoot an arrow
really I can mark you also got the bows
out of the chest so somehow you got
permissions the chest exploded you might
want to move Bob nope
give me in the face oh I just I just
timed this out trying to fix the
permissions
oh no oh why the heck am i ah why oh why
I go here oh let me to say that this is
probably the most professional minecraft
ism anyone has ever seen cannot read
talk no payment oh wow everybody on the
main server just got a little jolt a
screw um oh by the way anyone who's
watching this the link to the to the
server we were playing on the main
server is down in the description below
it's free to the public but there's a
website linking there you can donate to
the server to get rewards and help
contribute so please click on the link
and think about donating because it's a
great server and zombie here being the
owner is very understanding to me and us
because of all the [ __ ] around we do
I'm really surprised that he puts up
with any of us basically is obviously
understanding of Bob yeah that's why I
don't do anything
and I'm back I'm dead apparently to
start the game I have four messages hmm
oh that's a lot of zombies I want to get
to work guys
guys guys I can't do anything Bob are
you talking to your girlfriend or
something
no I'm not playing
you're not playing why'd you play down
playing okay there we go okay that's the
map actually functioning yes it's
actually working in there lots of
zombies I don't know where weight is
wait we're on a temple why I don't know
it's not like a join us and hey send me
to the temple hey get out here
I've got no bow here here here here here
there you go
you're already now bears don't use I'll
become zombies yay oh we can fire very
delayed Canada
are you shooting [ __ ] at me yes oh no I
originally didn't look out I'm it fired
it went to you it was actually pretty
awesome how this how this cycling number
system works I said you've really well
done I like that a lot
boom look how Bob I'm forcing the waves
oh yeah oh my god Bob look out
forcing another wave I'm forcing lots of
waves do it I'm forcing all the waves
but I do what I do we need some gassed
gassed that sounds phenomenal
yes a ghast attack Bob look out there
are zombies everywhere
I'm just Bo spamming them it seems to be
working
what that more waves good you do Belu
better
and coming oh they're getting kind of
close there I am dead oh my gosh we
didn't do that
Oh Martha the telazol incoming get him
good boom get your side get the friggin
TNT out I did a while ago you fairly
live that's what you do Bob where are
you I died
Oh I created a pit of death somehow
they're falling in ice and they're going
the wrong way
you blew up the middle there I don't
know how
okay I'm forcing more waves Buju they're
going the rope the zombies are going the
wrong way
who cares boo doo doo doo doo doo here
they come oh they are coming but I'll
bring it all but I do but I do but I do
boom oh yeah all the middle cut fixed
yay oh oh boy get up here and shoot some
TNT zombie wait her Bob needs to be
ported back I know you're probably busy
and annoyed at us oh there's Bob I know
I do not have a boat I'll give you both
but I don't have an arrow wait how many
arrows do you have it only shows one in
my inventory are they all congregating
around that spot it only shows me having
one in my inventory I don't know and
Bob's good you got it what is going on
there
is there like a scoring system where we
can lose if to mow no really wait again
oh they're following again Wade are you
died
are you dead am i died no I'm just I'm
standing on red wool man that's a lot of
zombies mark I think we might have just
blew up the map why what where what's
going on
are we gonna die I think so we got here
I kind of think so I'm back in the
temple I'm very concerned mark give me a
bow why I don't have one okay here you
go that is a lot of zombies I think I
broke the number system the TNT launcher
oh my goodness holy crap
do I hear music I do not know why are
you guys talking um I don't know aren't
y'all okay Bob behind you I'm killing
zombies I saved you it's okay that was a
nice shot thank you I wish my dear deal
Archer was working it broke real good
think you're out of TNT no I got plenty
but look the thing isn't working it's
all stuck oh hello
you okay over there Bob okay I got it
okay hey doing okay zoos I'm very
confused as why they're us like I am
legend they just are a hive look outward
why tt behind you I don't care like I
give a [ __ ] okay I think actually we're
out of time I'm not sure what the
cutting there and being an idiot that I
am I think we're out of time I think oh
man so zombie can we just get laid tnt
everywhere just blow these guys up oh we
need to get the outro going with TNT
alright just lots of TNT everywhere
everywhere wait a minute oh that's what
I'm talking yeah I'm alive I'm not Oh
shot myself oh my goodness alright so
that's gonna do it for the end of this
episode oh thank you all so much for
watching and as always we'll see you in
the next part
bye bye